let's go next to where do we want to go
next there are so many different people
uh oh you know who i want to go to let's
go to our friend
enrique from los angeles calling from
the three
two three we haven't heard from him for
ten can you believe that it's been
10 months since we heard from you
it's been 10 months yeah
wow it feels like yesterday i know
what's going on
hey i was i was watching your joe rogan
uh the lesson on jorgen yeah
and it was amazing man i love watching
you talk to people like joe rogan
uh just really quick yeah
i i i just think well on kyle kolinsky i
totally
i can't watch him anymore it really
upset me that he said that he won't
vote provided um did he say better
did he say that or did he say unless
biden comes around
on at least a couple of his five most
important
issues he said he's not voting for him
he's just not going to vote for biden
oh i didn't know that i didn't know that
right the latest i had heard and i
apologize you know i haven't looked at
twitter replies for five days as i
mentioned
the last i heard was kyle would vote for
him
if biden conceded or compromised on two
of kyle's top
five issues when i heard him he said
uh he said blame me for
trump's next win that's what he said you
can blame me and i'm okay with that oh
okay so i don't know about that
yeah but um i was gonna tell you so i
just think again
that um the left man i'm so worried
about this election
the left really needs to pull it
together again
the reason i'm not listening to kyle
kolinsky why is it that the left
cannot cannot even with a threat
like trump who's destroying this country
cannot come together why how come the
republicans
can get behind a man as a moral as
corrupt
a thief a con artist like
trump but we can't get behind together
for someone like biden yep i think biden
is not the best but come on and
it just infuriates me and also
the left is so weak at speaking to its
voters i i think i said this the last
time i was uh
10 10 months ago but why are we not
showing videos of how trump
is like a dictator how he's destroying
the justice system
how he's putting in judges that are
going to vote his way how he
is obstructing justice i mean why are we
not letting americans
know well enrique when you say when you
say why aren't we showing the videos
who is we are you like are you talking
about cnn or are you talking like who
are you talking about
i'm talking about okay i guess the dnc i
guess the people that are trying to get
him elected that are working getting
paid to get him elected
why are they not showing why are they
not strong look
i think the left is so weak
right now i had a conversation with my
brother yesterday he was like enrique
i'm so mad at the democrats right now
but of course i'm a provided
and he's very conservative hardcore
christian conservative but he's
he votes liberal and and i'm like yeah
that's true
we're so weak so let's go here's the
main thing i want to address that you
mentioned
why does the right seem to unite around
their candidate when the left
sometimes does not um i think that
this has a lot to do with the left
having more accelerationist tendencies
and more
opposition to incrementalism whereas the
right
if they've got a guy who talks about
grabbing by the [ __ ] has been married
three times
was pro-choice up until you know six
months before he ran for president
if he says i'll put people on the court
that will be against abortion that the
heritage foundation or whoever
suggests to me and i'll put in the right
judges
that's what they care they'll take it
they'll take they're like hey we're
gonna get something here we're not going
to get that with hillary
we're certainly not going to do anything
that helps hillary get elected let's put
trump in and you know what
now another trumpist president
is not completely unlikely it's possible
that now you could get another right
winger at some point
the left has a larger portion
of its makeup that is people
and i want to be clear i'm not talking
about kyle now he has said he's not an
accelerationist i want to be clear about
that
you have more people on the left who
they're not
missing the forest for the trees they
only care about
the forest so to speak and when they see
hey
biden gets you pick a number seventy
percent of what burton gets you 65 i
don't know what the number is
whereas trump gets you less than zero
uh they say we don't care you know maybe
we want to teach the dnc a lesson or
i'm not going to vote you know for a guy
who 20 years ago
said he would be open to policies that
he you know is certainly not running on
now or whatever the case
so when you have more accelerationism
in your political theory you will see
less
of a sort of uh uh coming together
uh to eliminate the greater evil or the
evil as i call it and as you call it
yeah yeah i mean that makes sense
enrique you're breaking up so i'm gonna
let you go you're coming in all choppy
like you're on a submarine but i'm gonna
let you go i so appreciate hearing from
you
uh we have enrique marked as a good
caller
good caller enrique from la let's take a
quick break
don't hang up if you're holding because
i will go right back to the phones it's
going to be incredible